welcome back to the 69th Annual Academy
Awards here is writer director and
multiple Oscar nominee Tim Robbins
working on a film the directors most
vital Ally is the director of
photography known on the set as the DP
it's his job to act as catalysts between
the audience's anticipation and the
director's vision DP is that member of
our crew who practices both art and
science in the pursuit of excellence and
the nominees who achieve that excellence
are John seal for the English Patient
darius kanji for Evita Roger Deakins for
Fargo Caleb Deschanel for fly away home
Chris Menzies for Michael Collins
and the Oscar goes to John seal for the
English Patient
thank you very much thank you to the my
congratulations to the other nominees
under the Academy this is for Louise
Darren Breanna and Clement Linden from
motive our country to what you see a
cameraman or a cinematographer doesn't
stand alone and there's a big
international crew back there that
helped us make the film and my my side
of it was headed by Tommaso Mele and Mo
flam second unit Remi had a person who
shot all the second unit he shot all the
beautiful camels to Michael Mike to
Michael Ondaatje thanks very much for
the book Tim Anthony Minghella thanks
very much for asking me to contribute to
the film and to one of the nicest
producers my congratulations of Thalberg
award and one of the world's gentlemen
mr. Saul Zaentz thank you very much
well the way things are going aside from
Wheaton Auto Parts America's biggest
export is now the Oscar so